foreign
hello and welcome to the view from 22
where we look at a new story that we
think hasn't been getting enough
attention I'm William Moore the
spectator's features editor today I'm
joined by Rory Sutherland The Spectators
Wiki man columnist who writes in his
most recent article for the magazine
that the case for living in London is
dwindling
Rory is it that you think it's getting
worse to live in London or is it that
other places in the country are
relatively getting better
so I think this is something you only
really notice if you're over 45 perhaps
um
I'm not suggesting that London's getting
worse a lot of people suggest New York
is getting worse
but what I'm certainly suggesting is
that the yawning Gulf that existed in
the 70s 80s and 90s between what you
might call consumption opportunities in
London and elsewhere
food drink entertainment Etc
uh has narrowed dramatically in that
London hasn't got all that much better
if I'm being counted about it uh you
know if you ask me to say how is London
better in 2023 than uh it was in 1990 uh
I'd have to point you I suppose the
Elizabeth line a few tube improvements
but nothing spectacular okay by contrast
if you go to what you might call
second-tier cities Cardiff Newcastle
Manchester Edinburgh
um the quality of food and drink General
entertainment
um
physically has massively improved by
which I mean that there was a kind of
almost kind of five to one or ten to one
ratio between London and anywhere else
in the country
um in terms of your opportunities for
interesting
um edifying consumption of some kind or
another
um and I don't think I don't think that
ratio is ten to one anymore I think it's
sort of you know 1.5 to 1 and that's
largely not because London's got worse
it might have got more annoying but I
don't think it's got worse in terms of
consumption no no it's definitely
improved
um however
um the the rest of the country has
caught up to a staggering degree and
that's without factoring in the digital
effect which is that obviously nearly
all online Commerce nearly all on online
entertainment Netflix Amazon Prime
whatever you want to call it is
basically the same everywhere
you know if you wanted to see a Korean
film in the 1990s you pretty much have
to live in London or somewhere with a
pretty obscure Art House Cinema now you
can go and find a lot of Korean Cinema
Online pretty easily you know again
retail you know you used to go to London
to see things that you hadn't seen
before well patently you know Amazon is
pretty much the same in Everest with uh
you know as it is in Islington so could
it be I'm really saying that and one of
the reasons I suspect this will continue
is simply the high London property
prices are driving out a kind of
creative class
in that all all societies have a kind of
battle between being rich and being cool
and it's perfectly possible to be one
and not the other Monaco is very very
rich but it's not even remotely cool
okay Berlin is immensely cooler than
wealthier German cities okay
and for a long time London kind of kept
its cool Alive by moving its heartlands
East
so in other words whereas I would have
thought of the center of London
meaningfully to be kind of you know
Knightsbridge in 1988 it's now kind of
farringdon or some people will go
further east still okay
um if it runs out of affordable property
for experimentation and what you find is
talented londoners moving out
in search of the space and affordable
property they need to fulfill their
dream as a rest return for example or
sculptor whatever it may be
um you have a you have a fundamental
problem for London in the sense that it
was always a better place to earn money
and will probably remain so although
flexible working slightly challenges
that Monopoly but it was also always a
much much better place to spend the
money
and where I live in Kent and where I
also have a bolt hole in East Kent I
keep noticing these fabulous restaurants
opening
um in places like folkestone where you
never would have dreamed of it happening
20 years ago which are basically opened
by London Exiles in search of
um you know
relatively same property prices in which
they can afford to experiment and
fulfill their dream yes well I live in
Sussex which um doesn't get a mention in
your article but I'll I'll take I'll
take Kent and I've noticed a similar
thing actually I was in Hastings uh the
weekend with my wife and kids and
there's lots of these sort of quite cool
uh restaurants and and wine bars and
stuff that would have been uh quite rare
to find in Hastings you know 30 years
ago or something yes and it is it's
London Exiles exactly exactly as you as
you say uh so it's like an extreme case
I went to Krakow and abergavenny now you
know growing up if you grew up in
Monmouth abigavenny was generally
portrayed as a complete dump and I have
a friend who grew up there as a child
who still cannot believe it when he
opens his Sunday times and um
abergavenny is presented as a food Mecca
but but these claims either these are
you know provincial towns with a
population of 20 000 you know these
claims are not totally ridiculous you go
there as a Londoner and you find them
very very interesting places yes and
genuinely you know I'll be able to see
candid when I went back to the if I went
back to abergavenny from London in the
late 80s or early 90s I would have been
crawling up the wall in about three or
four days so are you arguing Rory that
from sort of one way of looking at
things when we're talking about leveling
up rural communities or smaller towns
and so on are you arguing that actually
a lot of these places have innocence
already had a sort of leveling up
yeah so I mean maybe it's a kind of
asymmetry here in that I suppose The
World Isn't discovering new Cuisines
okay you know there aren't any
undiscovered Cuisines really of any
Merit and so it used to be if you just
take food as a kind of Benchmark it used
to be the fact that you know London you
would find Korean Lebanese you know
Vietnamese you know the whole canopy of
stuff whereas basically in the provinces
you had Often by the way a very good
Indian restaurant
um Indian food has always been
gloriously kind of democratic in terms
of where it chooses to dispense it's
it's glories but nonetheless there was
the Indian and there was the Chinese and
in the words of the comedian you know uh
Stuart Lee you know there's a Bella
pasta but you have to book you know it
was that kind of limitation and you
simply don't see that anymore that
actually that that provincial towns
repay curiosity at almost the same rate
that London does yes so you mentioned
that in your in your piece that London
is sort of doubly hit if you live in
London because you have now a situation
where you pay rent uh or or a London
mortgage it's a lot of a lot of money
you're losing uh each month to that but
then additionally there are sort of
fewer places that make it worth spending
money in London relative to the rest of
the country yes and most of the action
there I mean London will always be a
massive uh in a sense it'll always be a
massive spur to Innovation simply
because of the different people who
Collide there but what I am saying is
that what you might call the London
Newcastle London Manchester Gap and even
some extent you know the London
Tunbridge Wells Gap is simply not what
it was
um you know the London to Hastings Gap
okay
um and so in terms of kind of hipster
opportunities and kind of curious
opportunities for uh interesting forms
of consumption it's not it's not the
fact that you know no one in
pembrokeshire knows what a latte is
you know you can forget about that
you'll probably find a coffee shop
that's as good in Haverford West I'm
really sticking my neck out here because
I haven't been to Hanford
but but my hunch is that there's a
pretty cool you know
um uh coffee shop uh in in Hanford West
where you can get something which is as
good as you know uh everything but the
weirdest place in shortage whereas you
know previously you know uh
sushi would be another example but I
mean it does seem to be fundamentally
interesting and of course I mentioned
the digital role in this that you don't
feel cut off from either other people
uh no and it only requires a certain
amount of a London Exodus to provide
critical mass I think for people to move
elsewhere
well that critical mass is important
isn't it because part of the reason that
people are reluctant to move out of
London it isn't just a sort of consumer
point about what you can and can't buy
it's about the other types of people who
are there and there's an interesting
question to be looked at there which is
undoubtedly no one's going to argue this
for a second there are more interesting
people in London than anywhere else in
the UK quantitatively okay
the difference I noticed between that
and deal where I go for General sort of
escapes from time to time is in London
you meet a hundred interesting people
but you meet them once a year
in deal there are 20 interesting people
whom you meet five times a year and
actually meeting the same interesting
people repeatedly is more akin to a
proper relationship than having these
kind of Fairly fleeting encounters with
Fascinating People all of which by the
way require you know six weeks
pre-planning in order to happen
that's one of the great things about
smaller places is there's some evidence
that people are happiest in Market towns
and there's this very strange measure of
happiness to to in fact having more than
one pair of shoes for some weird reason
seems to correlate with the elevated
level is it that is it that weird Rory
having having uh it's not that weird is
it I I think this is at the global level
for some reason there's some sort of
discretionary income
um point now we've kind of I guess we've
got to reach that I hope the spectators
pay you at least enough to have more
than one pair of shoes but there's
another one which is regularly bumping
into people you like without planning it
so regular Random Encounters with people
you like and whose company you enjoy
without forward planning
seems to correlate pretty well with
human well-being so there's this
interesting possibility that if you move
to a smaller place yes okay there are
fewer interesting people for you to meet
in theory but in practice you meet those
fewer interesting people more frequently
and also more randomly
and therefore it contributes more to
your general happiness
I don't know about you but I mean if had
you gone to Hastings I would guess in
you know 1995 it would have been
Unthinkable for you to move there yeah
and I suspect you had a little Shifty
around a few estate agents windows down
there yeah if only out of curiosity yeah
absolutely no I love Hastings I think
it's an extremely interesting town and
and a huge musical community of course
it interestingly it's a beneficiary of a
bad commute
and the reason is the property prices
were never that expensive because for
nine to five five days a week commuting
Hastings had two poor and actually quite
an unreliable service now if you're a
musician or an artist you need to be in
London three days a week and it's
probably an off-peak ticket Hastings is
perfect because your travel costs aren't
all that egregious you're not competing
with Bankers to get on the train or
paying a full fare ticket and actually
you know musicians generally don't start
at nine so you've always had this kind
of interesting artistic Community which
Springs up as a product of low property
prices
and so when so I yeah I do I high
property prices frighten me because when
you're paying a lot for Real Estate you
can't take risks and risks are
ultimately what makes Commerce
interesting
well can we ask can we talk a bit about
commuting because uh you you've written
in a few of your Working Man columns now
about how you think flexi working is
going to change people's uh habits uh
more and and a lot of people are
sticking with Flexi working even now the
the pandemic is is over I mean do you
think that freezer is a bit of a lud it
isn't the Fraser wants everybody in The
Spectator at nine o'clock yeah very much
likes uh being in the office yes
um the only irony is that the entire
magazine is basically written by people
at home yeah okay the entire contents of
the magazine are produced by people at
home writing away in a back bedroom and
then pressing send I think that's great
benefit for us for us all being here in
the office to sort of knock ideas about
but um but in terms of places like let's
let's go back to Gerald Hastings uh do
you think that that its future uh looks
even brighter because of things like
flexi working they're going to be more
people who who think well if I had to go
to London every day of the week I can't
live in Hastings but if it's only two
days a week three days a week then
so one thing is just if property prices
stagnate in London and go up elsewhere
one of the reasons to stay in London
which is I'm frightened of leaving
London for fear of missing out on Future
Property browse gains or being unable to
afford to move back
you know I I also think there was a lot
of adaptive preference formation about
London people paid such a high price to
live there that they convinced
themselves that it was worthwhile they'd
always type things like the theater even
though when you quiz them they hadn't
been for 18 months you know
um
and yeah there's concert going if you're
single okay tinder's always going to be
a lot better in London than it is in
Hastings let's be candid although if
you're into something really deviant
who knows I'm already pleased we might
have viewers and Hastings I've got to be
careful
but but um
they're always they're always huge
upsides but there's a very very big
change which is if you had to be in the
office at nine o'clock on a peak season
ticket five days a week your move out
and bear in mind dual income households
made this even more painful because for
two people working in London to commute
out you're effectively committing to two
season tickets
and in return you got two days by the
seaside and five days of a grueling and
expensive commute
with some measure of flexible working
even if it's just the famous [__]
formula which is you're in London
Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday
[__] okay
um with some measure of flexible working
whoa let's say you're going to London
two or three days a week you might be
getting five days by the seaside in
return for two days of a commute one of
which might be on an off-peak ticket
which off-peak day return which costs
you almost nothing
so
there's something there's something
fundamental about that ratio which is it
used to be five to two in favor of
London and now it's arguably five to two
in favor of Hastings now that's a ratio
of 25 over four which is 6.25 which
suggests that moving out to Hastings is
now 6.25 times more appealing than it
once was
that's a big factor
so when you reverse a ratio five to two
versus two to five that's a big number
mathematically
and I think you know I think we have to
just
accept the fact that um
this is not bad news by the way because
you know I'm a geologist and one of the
things I notice one of the things I
agree with Henry George about is that
whenever economic activity depends on
its location for its performance
increasingly the gains don't go to the
worker they go to the landowner or the
Freeholder and I think London is an
appalling rent-seeking bloody economy
actually it's a rich economy but
actually the people actually producing
the wealth don't yet see very much of it
compared to the people who are you know
the buy to let landlords and the
commercial property owners who are
effectively just sucking out most of the
gains but didn't have you know a kind of
modern day feudalism
and um if you take our younger stuff I'm
fine okay I'm 57 I kind of rode a bit of
a property wave I bought property when
it was still relatively sane if you look
at my junior colleagues in their 20s and
30s after they've paid tax 50 of their
increment 50 of their after-tax income
basically will go on accommodation and
transportation
now you know that's not good for the fun
economy
you know it's an enormous essentially
it's an enormous absorption of what
could be discretionary wealth into the
hands of uh you know General rent
seeking landlords and tfl
who opens in Mayfair okay
you know well
essentially you can understand I mean
you know where I'm in Deal one of one of
the restaurants has a chef who came from
the um uh the Chilton Firehouse there's
an extraordinary place called Uptown
house which has opened in a farmhouse
sort of five miles out of town now what
they've done is
they've started from a basis where we
don't have to pick fifty thousand a
month to break even it's a wonderful
place from which to start
and so I can actually see it where where
the cool rather than moving to hoxton or
to shoreditch the cool actually moves to
Margate or Hastings
I think I think that's a perfectly
plausible thing we should anticipate and
actually you know uh if you're looking
to invest in something beachfront or
Seaside property uh is probably as hot
as it gets
tomorrow belongs to Hastings Rory
absolutely Rory thank you very much
indeed for joining me thank you huge
pleasure thank you very much indeed
foreign
[Music]